[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: You know,
mankind is a symbolic species,
which means that even physical
pleasures-- trivial things
for other animals, mating
habits, eating, reproduction,
so and so forth-- to us
become cosmic acts impregnated
with significance.
We are travelers in
search of signification,
and so even sensuality has
been turned into poetry.
Apes have sex, human
beings make love, you know.
And Alan Harrington has this
great line where he says,
sensuality may itself
turn into a feverish hunt
for rebirth, for apotheosis,
for symbolic catharsis.
And I just love this idea that
us-- as this meaning making
species, this symbolic
representational species-- all
the pleasure that we seem
to get from the world
comes from the story
we tell ourselves
about that experience.
Like, we become the paint
brush, we become the meaning.
We are the answer to the
question we're asking,
and I think that
loop is fascinating.
[MUSIC PLAYING]